[Musica]
un paio d'anni fa mentre viaggiava in
treno verso new york sono stata colpita
da questo cartello che ha fotografato i
tweet non sono la storia intera e ho
pensato che vale non solo per i tweet ma
vale per gli articoli di giornale per i
post su facebook per le news dei
telegiornali e mi ha fatto riflettere su
che cosa è la verità
nell'era della comunicazione e nell'era
cosiddetta della post verità dove pare
che le emozioni contino più dei fatti e
gli effetti che si raggiungono chiude la
verità dei fatti stessi
allora ho pensato che questo intero
nessuno può dire di possederlo non solo
ma per ricostruirlo serve il contributo
di tutti e quindi il dialogo è una
componente fondamentale della ricerca di
questa verità
nell'era così complessa che viene
chiamata l'era dell'antropocene cioè
dove l'ambiente naturale e ormai
colonizzato dalla tecnica e dai frutti
dell'azione dell'uomo e addirittura del
cripto cene cioè dove gli algoritmi
costruiscono realtà e guidano i nostri
comportamenti
allora la sfida è possibile pensare a
una comunicazione umana
in questo contesto ci sono gli
apocalittici e gli integrati come diceva
umberto eco i tecno pessimisti e techno
ottimisti i tecno pessimisti dicono che
la comunicazione interumana è ostacolata
dalla tecnica bank sila rappresentato
così la famosa psicanalista e sociologa
share it arco dice che siamo soli
insieme fisicamente contigui ma
disconnessi gli uni dagli altri e questo
è un po letto come un effetto della
comunicazione digitale
ma è davvero così forse anche nel
passato i media tradizionali ci
servivano per isolarci dal contatto
oculare che è sempre un invito alla
comunicazione
allora forse dobbiamo riflettere al di
là di questi schemi semplicistici causa
effetto la comunicazione digitale
facilità o impedisce la comunicazione
tra di noi
anche perché se abbracciamo questa
logica di causa effetto dovremmo dire
che noi abbiamo cambiato il modo di fare
colazione e mangiamo tosta l'avocado
perché viene meglio su instagram del
pane con la marmellata e quindi la
comunicazione digitale ei social hanno
stravolto i nostri modi di vivere ma in
realtà se noi guardiamo un po più
indietro
vediamo che anche nell'era televisiva il
pallone da calcio ha cambiato forma e
colore per essere più visibile agli
spettatori durante le partite e quindi
la parola d'ordine non è manipolazione
ma è accessibilità e condivisione
personalmente sono molto scettica
rispetto alla logica causa effetto la
logica di un determinismo la tecnica
produce questi effetti anche perché se
sposiamo la logica causa effetto
ci sono delle discrepanze anche tra
autori e studiosi molto importanti della
comunicazione come vedete da questi due
titoli quindi la rete ci rende stupidi
ci rende intelligenti forse non ci rende
forse costituisce un ambiente che ci
sfida che ci provoca ci sono molti
luoghi comuni che dobbiamo cercare di
smontare il dualismo è uno di questi
il determinismo il fatto che la
comunicazione digitale non ci sottrae
possibilità di comunicare tra di noi
perché viviamo on life cioè viviamo in
un ambiente che ormai è visto che ormai
dove ormai la dimensione fisica e quella
digitale sono strettamente intrecciate
questo vuol dire che i media non sono
degli strumenti lo strumento è un
martello che sta in un cassetto che tiro
fuori quando devo piantare il chiodo e
che poi rimesso via e non condizionano
non modifica il mio modo di vivere
ma questi media sono sempre attivi noi
viviamo siamo ora in un posto dove ci
sono luci artificiali
i microfoni collegamenti e questo è il
nostro ambiente tra virgolette naturale
in questo ambiente on life noi
diventiamo chi siamo noi prendiamo forma
e prendendo forma diamo forma
all'ambiente e forse questa è una nuova
idea di informazione prendere forma e
dare forma forse se avessimo questa
questa idea di che cosa significa
informare prendere forma e dare forma
avremo un senso di responsabilità un po
più alto nei confronti di quello che ci
sta intorno
noi sogniamo in realtà abbiamo un po
paura del contesto in cui viviamo
assumiamo una comunicazione sogniamo una
società a rischio zero e anche una
comunicazione a rischio zero perché
abbiamo in mente che la comunicazione si
deve modellare sul linguaggio
scientifico che è un linguaggio dove i
termini sono univoci indicano sono
etichette che aderiscono perfettamente a
quell'oggetto a quella sostanza è solo a
quella quindi se io dico h2o è una
formula che non ha possibilità di essere
fraintesa però un grandissimo filosofo
del novecento paul ricard diceva che la
comunicazione tra persone tra esseri
umani non è un fatto ma un miracolo non
è un dato ma un miracolo un miracolo che
qualche volta accade ma che appunto è
nasconde il fatto che la normalità è il
malinteso e il fraintendimento o una
comunicazione che cerca di manipolare
perché noi non usiamo solo termini la
scienza usa solo termini e va benissimo
ma non possiamo trasferire questo sogno
di etichette senza resto alla
comunicazione umana perché la
comunicazione umana fatta di parole
allora se io dico acqua dico qualche
cosa che ha mille significati 10.000
significati simbolici vuol dire purezza
vuol dire vita vuol dire lavarsi da ciò
che
e sporco vuol dire poter condividere una
quotidianità semplice vuol dire
tantissimo
allora la comunicazione umana è fatta di
parole e non di termini e i termini sono
etichette le parole sono finestre che
aprono su mondi di significato che sono
inesauribili che sono sempre arricchiti
da significati nuove che ci scambiamo
nella nostra comunicazione
purtroppo noi abbiamo in mente un'idea
riduttiva di comunicazione come
trasmissione di messaggi come
trasferimento di contenuti da
un'emittente a un ricevente non che
questa accezione non non esista ma è
molto molto riduttiva e non è
tipicamente umana perché un modello
comunicativo che accade anche tra
macchine una macchina emette un segnale
codificato in un linguaggio l'altra
macchina la decodifica non è specifica
della comunicazione umana
inoltre è un modello rigido questo
perché emittente messaggio e ricevente
non si modificano nel corso dell'intera
azione semplicemente c'è una specie di
nastro trasportatore che porta un
contenuto da un punto a a un punto b il
contenuto rimane lo stesso anzi in
questo modello il rischio è che in
questo passaggio si perda informazione
ci siano degli elementi di rumore che
impediscono una corretta decodifica del
messaggio e in più è rigido perché
appunto questi tre elementi
4 se ci mettiamo anche il codice restano
tali e quali nel corso di questa di
questa trasformazione di questa
interazione
non è questo il modello di comunicati di
comunicazione che caratterizza noi
esseri umani perché non è questo perché
nella comunicazione dialogica dialogo
vuol dire logos parola che unisce due
distanze di a come diaspora
diagonale nella comunicazione dialogica
che la comunicazione interpersonale
tutto è connesso siamo connessi noi che
comunichiamo siamo connessi a un
ambiente che non è mai indifferente che
ci condiziona ma nello stesso tempo che
noi plasmiamo a cui noi possiamo dare
una forma e in questa reciprocità in
questa dinamica di interazioni complesse
non riducibili a rapporti di causa
effetto
in questa dinamica noi prendiamo forma e
diamo forma al mondo
e guardate questo accade nell'era
digitale anche per chi non usa i media
digitali perché l'ambiente in cui noi
viviamo è appunto un ambiente misto un
ambiente online come anche chi non ha la
patente subisce gli effetti di città che
sono costruite per viaggiare sulle
automobili
quindi non possiamo tirarci fuori da
questa da questa on life misto materiale
digitale possiamo decidere come abitarlo
possiamo decidere che cosa significa
vivere questa reciprocità dentro un
ambiente misto
allora forse dovremmo cambiare un po la
nostra idea di che cosa significa
diventare persone non è semplicemente
tirare fuori ciò che già siamo ma
costruirci in relazione a ciò che ci
interpella ci provoca ci mette in
movimento è un dinamismo che
caratterizza la comunicazione
interpersonale
noi non siamo individui che costruiscono
relazioni che affermano che trasmettono
contenuti ma noi siamo esseri che si
individuano che continuamente prendono
forma che diventano chi sono nel tempo
in relazione con l'ambiente e con altre
persone e comunicare
non è in questo contesto dire qualcosa a
qualcuno o trasmettere un contenuto che
già tutto presente nella nostra testa
comunicare è appunto partire da una
situazione di fraintendimento di
distanza di fatica comprendersi e
cercare di ridurre questa distanza
comunicare alla radice communis che vuol
dire appunto mettere in comune costruire
un mondo comune da abitare insieme è una
rivoluzione rispetto all'idea della
trasmissione ha un'idea rigida in cui io
ho la mia verità e te la dico
è una rivoluzione rispetto al mondo
delle sei ti news che spazzano la
comunità perché tu ti devi schierare da
una parte o dall'altra
io penso che il significato autentico
della comunicazione sia esattamente il
contrario cioè ridurre le distanze
ritessere legami ricucire il tessuto
sociale con piccoli passi nel tempo e
non nello schieramento spaziale che
richiedono le faq chiuse nel tempo
ricucire queste distanze c'è l'ultima
cosa che vorrei dire la dico con l'opera
di uno dei miei scultori preferiti che
ho chiuso rodin questo questa scultura
che ho visto personalmente si chiama il
segreto ed è una bella immagine perché
della nostra insieme fatica e desiderio
di comunicare allora queste due mani una
maschile e una femminile si toccano in
un punto perché se non ci fosse nemmeno
un punto di contatto
noi non potremmo scambiarci nessuna
comunicazione non potremmo ridurre
nessuna distanza
nello stesso tempo tra queste due mani
c'è il corpo misterioso c'è un qualcosa
di solido di opaco perché noi
comunicando non possiamo mai pretendere
che l'altro ci sia trasparente
pretendere di capire tutto di spiegare
ogni cosa e soprattutto di farlo
immediatamente con un click
ci vuole la pazienza di ridurre questo
volume di ridurre questa distanza
sapendo da una parte che non potrà mai
essere cancellata del tutto e dall'altra
parte che non possiamo mai smettere di
desiderare di ridurla questa distanza
allora questo è il desiderio che ci fa
continuare a camminare verso gli altri
questo è il desiderio che rende la
nostra la qualità della nostra
comunicazione molto più alta in questa
tensione feconda tra nascondimento e
svelamento tra presente
dell'incomprensione futuro di una
speranza di comprensione tra trasparenze
opacità
in tutto questo la comunicazione si
arricchisce e se si arricchisce la
comunicazione diventa anche molto più
abitabile il mondo che abbiamo intorno
[Applauso]
[Musica]